es wird gesprengt in Deutschland
Geldautomaten sind nach wie vor beliebte
Ziele bei europäischen Räuberbanden fast
täglich explodiert irgendwo in der
Republik ein Automat freistehend oder
auch in Eingängen von Sparkassen und
anderen Häusern verbunden mit akuter
Gefahr für Anwohner und Passanten die
entstandenen Sachschäden sind meist
höher als die Beute deutlicher
Schwerpunkte Angriffe
Nordrhein-Westfalen
naja NRW ist beliebt weil wir halt der
unmittelbare Nachbarin sind und von
daher der Grenzübergang und unsere
Verkehrsinfrastruktur eine optimale Tat
Gelegenheit bieten hauptsächlich
niederländische Tätergruppen sind in
Deutschland aktiv der Überfall selbst
dauert maximal 2 Minuten dann wird mit
einem schnellen meist ebenfalls
gestohlenen Wagen die Flucht der Griffen
die Täter fahren dabei rücksichtslos und
riskant und wenn es ihnen gelingt die
Grenze zu überqueren verliert sich die
Spur
das zeigt diese Karte abgesehen von
Berlin ist NRW der absolute Schwerpunkt
der Sprengungen und immer liegen die
Ziele direkt an der Autobahn in
Utrecht hat die niederländische Polizei
ein Trainingszentrum in tarnt hier
wurden automatensprengungen regelrecht
geübt
da haben wir konkrete Hinweise dass die
Täter sich dezidiert auf die Taten
vorbereiten und auch die Tatausführung
üben das erklärt natürlich auch dann
auch die geringend Tat dauern bzw die
Dauer der Tatzeiten inzwischen hat auch
das Hessische Landeskriminalamt zu
Untersuchungszwecken Geldautomaten
gesprengt dabei wurde die enorme Wirkung
von festen Sprengstoffen gegenüber Gas
dokumentiert
[Musik]
die Banken reagieren unterdessen immer
öfter damit keine Geldautomaten mehr
anzubieten nur noch sehr selten findet
man einen Automaten direkt auf der
Straße das gefällt nicht jedem das
natürlich für Kunden nicht so schön und
die Geldautomaten sollte man ja weiter
nutzen können das sollte ja nicht so
sein wenn die da Gewalt
zusammen zerstört werden dass man dann
keine Möglichkeit hat mehr sein Geld in
seiner Nähe abzuheben also für die
jungen Leute ist ja gerade noch mal so
weil die Zahlen überall mit Karte oder
haben wir online aber für die alte Leute
die sich nicht so gut auskennen
normalerweise es sind schöne
laden oder Bäckerei und so man braucht
Schein oder
Geldautomaten reinmachen die dann
explodieren der Farbe drin ist dass die
mit dem Geld nicht anfangen können dann
wäre noch keine automatisch bringt oder
nutzlos ist genau davor schrecken einige
Banken aber wohl zurück statt das Geld
unbrauchbar zu machen setzen sie auf Gas
Neutralisation das wiederum treibt die
Gewaltspirale fester Sprengstoff statt
Gas die Täter rüsten auch auf
das ist tatsächlich so leider natürlich
erhöht das die Gefährdung für Dritte und
für unsere Einsatzkräfte für alle
Beteiligten einschließlich der Täter
enorm wir können eigentlich von Glück
sagen dass da bis dato noch nicht
schlimmeres passiert ist sondern dass es
häufig bei leichten Verletzungen oder
bei Traumata der entsprechenden
Betroffenen insbesondere bei Anwohnern
geblieben ist aber ja das ist richtig
die Nutzung von Explosivstoffen erhöht
deutlich das Risiko einfach fahren bei
dem das Geld im Automaten zu einem Block
verklebt wird schaltet aus weil die
Bundesbank den Banken diese geldblöcke
nicht ersetzt in den Niederlanden selbst
geht die Zahl der gesprengten
Geldautomaten gegen 0 konsequent
arbeiten die Banken hier mit der Polizei
zusammen
was wir in den Niederlanden anders
machen als bei euch ist dass wir um das
Sprengen von Geldautomaten zu verhindern
mit den Banken verhandelt haben dass die
Automaten rund um die Uhr bewacht und
beschützt werden das macht es so schwer
und unattraktiv für Räuber diese
Automaten zu springen
dazu kommt dass man Bargeld in die
Niederlanden kaum noch braucht
in den gesamten Niederlanden gibt es nur
noch rund 1000 Geldautomaten einfach
weil die bargeldkultur eine völlig
andere ist alleine in
Nordrhein-Westfalen gibt es rund 10.000
Geldautomaten eine Bande allerdings fuhr
für die Einbrüche sogar von Roermond bis
nach Bayern insgesamt 12 Täter räumten
hier immer wieder rund um Bamberg
Geldautomaten aus über internationale
dna-vergleiche gelangten die Ermittler
schließlich auf ihre Spur
am
30.01.2023 kamen schließlich zum Vollzug
von insgesamt neun Haftbefehlen in den
Niederlanden
im Rahmen einer Vielzahl von
gleichzeitig durchgeführten
Durchsuchungen konnte umfangreiches
Beweismaterial sichergestellt werden die
Auslieferung der festgenommenen
Tatverdächtigen nach Deutschland ist von
uns von der Staatsanwaltschaft Bamberg
bereits beantragt worden ein seltener
Erfolg internationaler Zusammenarbeit
über Grenzen hinweg aber solange in
Deutschland noch so gerne bar bezahlt
wird wird die Gefahr bleiben die
Einbrüche lohnen sich am Wochenende sind
in bestimmten Automaten bis zu 300.000
Euro enthalten
[Musik]